the following is a conversation with
David Chalmers he's a philosopher and
cognitive scientist specializing in the
areas of philosophy of mind
philosophy language and consciousness
he's perhaps best known for formulating
the hard problem of consciousness which
could be stated as why does the feeling
which accompanies awareness of sensory
information exists at all consciousness
is almost entirely mystery many people
who worry about AI safety in ethics
believe that in some form consciousness
can and should be engineered into AI
systems of the future so while there's
much mystery disagreement and
discoveries yet to be made about
consciousness these conversations while
fundamentally philosophical in nature
may nevertheless be very important for
engineers of modern AI systems to engage
in this is the artificial intelligence
podcast if you enjoy it subscribe on
YouTube give it five stars an Apple
podcast supported on patreon or simply
connect with me on Twitter at lex
friedman spelled fri DM a.m. as usual
i'll do one or two minutes of ads now
and never any ads in the middle that can
break the flow of the conversation I
hope that works for you and doesn't hurt
the listening experience the show is
presented by cash app the number-one
finance app in the App Store when you
get it you scolex vodcast cash app lets
you send money to friends buy Bitcoin
and invest in the stock market with as
little as $1 brokerage services are
provided by kept investing subsidiary of
Square and member s IPC since cash app
does fractional share trading let me
mention that the order execution
algorithm that works behind the scenes
to create the abstraction of fractional
orders is an algorithmic marvel so big
props to the cash app engineers for
solving a hard problem that in the end
provides an easy interface that takes a
step up to the next layer of abstraction
over the stock market making trading
more accessible for new investors and
diversification much easier if you get
cash app from the App Store or Google
Play and use the code lex podcast you'll
get $10 and cash app will also donate
$10 to first one of my favorite
organizations
helping to advance robotics and STEM
education for young people around the
world and now here's my conversation
with David Chalmers do you think we're
living in a simulation I don't rule it
out there's probably going to be a lot
of simulations in the history of the
cosmos if the simulation is designed
well enough it'll be indistinguishable
from a non simulated reality and
although we could keep searching for
evidence that were not in a simulation
any of that evidence in principle could
be simulated so I think it's a
possibility but do you think the thought
experiment is interesting or useful to
calibrate how we think about the nature
of reality yeah I definitely think it's
interesting and useful in fact I'm
actually writing a book about this right
now all about the simulation idea using
it to shed light on a whole bunch of
philosophical questions so you know the
big one is how do we know anything about
the external world Descartes said you
know maybe you're being fooled by an
evil demon who's stimulating your brain
and thinking all this stuff is real when
in fact it's all made up well the modern
the modern version of that is how do you
know you're not in a simulation then the
thought is if you're in a simulation
none of this is real
so that's teaching you something to give
out about knowledge how do you know
about the external world I think there's
also really interesting questions about
the nature of reality right here I mean
if we are in a simulation is all this
real
is there really a table here is it
really a microphone do I really have a
body the standard view would be no we
don't none of this would be real my view
is actually that's wrong and even if we
are in a simulation
all of this is real that's why I called
this reality 2.0 new version of reality
different version of reality still
reality so what's the difference between
quote-unquote real world and the world
that we perceive so that we interact
with the world to the world by
perceiving it it only really exists
through the window of our perception
system and in our mind so
differs means something that's
quote-unquote real that exists perhaps
without us being there and and the the
world a as you perceive it well the
world as we perceive it as a very
simplified and distorted version of
what's going on underneath we already
know that from just thinking about
science you know you don't see too many
obviously quantum mechanical effects and
what we what we perceive but we still
know quantum mechanics is going on under
all things so I like to think the world
we perceive is this very kind of
simplified picture of colors and shapes
existing and in space and so on we know
there's a that's what the philosopher
Wilfrid Sellars called the manifest
image the world as it seems to us we
already know underneath all that is a
very different scientific image with
atoms or quantum wave functions or super
strings or whatever the the latest thing
is and that's the ultimate scientific
reality so I think of the simulation
idea as basically another hypothesis
about what the ultimate se quasi
scientific or metaphysical reality is
going on underneath the world with a
manifest image the world of the manifest
image is this very simple thing that we
interact with it's neutral on the
underlying stuff of reality science
could help tell us about that maybe
philosophy could help tell us about that
- and if we eventually take the red pill
and find out we're in a simulation in my
view is that's just another view about
what reality is made of you know the
philosopher Immanuel Kant said what is
the nature of the thing in itself I've
got a glass here and it's got all these
it appears to me a certain way a certain
shape it's liquid it's clear and he said
what is the nature of the thing and
itself well I think of the simulation
idea it's a hypothesis about the nature
of the thing in itself it turns out if
we're in a simulation the thing in
itself nature of this glass okay it's
actually a bunch of data structures
running on a on a computer in the next
universe up yeah that's what people tend
to do and they think about simulation
they think about our modern computers
and somehow trivially crudely just
scaled up and
but do you think the simulation I mean
in order to actually simulate something
as complicated as our universe that's
made up of molecules and atoms and
particles and quarks and maybe even
strings all of that requires something
just infinitely many orders of magnitude
more of scale and complexity do you
think we're even able to even like
conceptualize what it would take to
simulate our universe or does it just
slip into this idea that you basically
have to build a universe something so
big to simulate it is that it just get
this into this fuzzy area that's not
useful at all yeah well obviously I mean
our universe is obviously incredibly
complicated and for us within our
universe to build a simulation of a
universe as complicated as ours is gonna
have obvious problems here if the
universe is finite there's just no way
that's gonna work maybe there's some
cute way to make it work if the universe
is a is a is infinite maybe an infinite
universe could somehow simulate a copy
of itself but that's a that's gonna be
hard
nonetheless just that we are in a
simulation I think there's no particular
reason why we have to think the
simulating universe has to be anything
like ours you've said before that it
might be so you can think of it and
Turtles all the way down you could think
of the simulating universe different
than ours but we ourselves could also
create another simulating universe so
you said there could be these kind of
levels of universes and you've also
mentioned this hilarious idea maybe
tongue-in-cheek maybe not that there may
be simulations within simulations
arbitrarily stacked levels and that
there may be that we may be in level 42
oh yeah along those stacks referencing
Hitchhiker's Guide to the universe if
we're indeed in a simulation within a
simulation at level 42 what do you think
level zero looks like there right would
expect that
zero is truly enormous I mean not just
if it's finite it's some extraordinarily
large finite capacity much more likely
its infinite maybe it's a maybe it's got
something very high etcetera to
cardinalities that enables it to support
just any number of any number of
simulations so high degree of infinity
at level zero slight little slightly
smaller degree of infinity at at level
one so by the time you get down to us at
level 42 maybe plenty of room for lots
of simulations of finite capacity if the
top universe is only a small finite
capacity then obviously that's going to
put very very serious limits on how many
simulations are going to be able to be
able to get running so I think we can
certainly confidently say that if we
hurt level 42 then the top level is
pretty pretty damn big so it gets more
and more constrained as we get down
levels more and more simplified and
constrained and limited resources and
you know we still have plenty of
capacity here what was it a Fineman 30
said there's plenty of room at the
bottom you know we're still you know
we're still a number of levels above the
degree where there's room for
fundamental computing physical computing
capacity quantum computing capacity at
the bottom level so we got plenty of
room to play with and make we probably
have plenty of room for simulations of
pretty sophisticated universes perhaps
none as complicated as our universe
unless our universes is infinite but
still it's very least for pretty serious
finite universes but maybe universes
somewhat simpler than ours unless of
course we're prepared to take certain
shortcuts in the simulation which might
then increase their capacity
significantly do you think the the human
mind us people in terms of the
complexity of simulation as at the
height of what the simulation might be
able to achieve like if you look at
incredible entities that could be
created in this universe of ours do you
have an intuition about how incredible
human beings are on that scale I think
we're pretty impressive
we're not that impressive are we above
average
I mean I think high human beings are a
certain point in the scale of
intelligence which made many things
possible you know you get through
evolution through single-cell organisms
through fish and mammals and primates
and something happens once you get to
human beings we've just reached that
level where we get to develop language
we get to develop certain kinds of
culture or maybe get to develop certain
kinds of collective thinking that has
enabled all this amazing stuff to happen
science and literature and engineering
and culture and and so on so we had just
at the beginning of that on the
evolutionary threshold it's kind of like
we just got there you know who knows a
few thousands or tens of thousands of
years ago so we're probably just at the
very beginning for what's possible there
so I'm inclined to think among the scale
of intelligent beings we're somewhere
very near the bottom I would expect that
for example if we're in a if we're in a
simulation then the simulators who
created a sir got the capacity to be far
more sophisticated for at level 42 who
knows what the ones at level zero I like
it's also possible that this is the
epitome of what is possible to achieve
so we as human beings see ourselves
maybe as flawed see all the constraints
all the limitations but maybe that's the
magical the beautiful thing
maybe those limitations are the
essential elements for an interesting
sort of that edge of chaos that
interesting existence that if you make
us much more intelligent if if you make
us much more powerful in any kind of
dimension of performance maybe you lose
something fundamental that makes life
worth living so you kind of have this
optimistic view of where this little
baby that and there's so much growth and
potential but this could also be it well
this is the most amazing thing is us
maybe what you're saying is consistent
with what I'm saying I mean we can still
have levels of intelligence far beyond
us but maybe those levels of
intelligence on your view would be kind
of boring and
you know we get kind of get so good at
everything that life suddenly becomes
uni-dimensional
so we're just in happening in happening
this once part of like maximal
romanticism and history of evolution yes
you get to humans and it's like yeah and
then years to come our super intelligent
descendents are gonna look back at us
and say those were the days when and
they just hit the point of inflection
and life was interesting I am an
optimist so I'd like to think that you
know if there is super intelligence
somewhere in the in the future they'll
figure out how to make life super
interesting and super romantic when you
know what they're gonna do it so what
they're gonna do is they realize how
boring life is when you're super
intelligent so they created a new level
of a simulation and sort of live through
the things they've created by watching
them stumble about in their flawed ways
so maybe that's so you create a new
level of a simulation every time you get
really bored with how smart and this
would be kind of sad though because it
would show the peak of their existence
would be like watching simulations for
entertainment by saying the peak of our
existence now is Netflix know it's
alright a flipside of that could be the
peak of our existence for many people
having children and watching them grow
hmm that becomes very meaningful
okay so create a simulation it's like
creating a family creating like well any
kind of creation is uh it's kind of a
powerful act dealing is easier to
simulate the mind or the universe so
I've heard several people including Nick
Bostrom think about ideas of you know
maybe you don't need to simulate the
universe you can just simulate the human
mind or in general just the distinction
between simulating this the entirety of
it the entirety the physical world or
just simulating the mind which one do
you see is more challenging well I think
in some sense the answer is is obvious
it has to be simpler to simply simulate
the mind than to simulate the universe
because the mind is part of the universe
and in order to fully simulate the
universe you're gonna have to simulate
the mind's eye just by talking about
partial simulations and I guess the
question is which comes first there's a
mind come before the universe or does
the universe come before the mind
so the mind could just be an emergent
phenomena in this universe so simulation
is a is an interesting thing that you
know it's it's not like creating a
simulation perhaps requires you to
program every single thing that happens
in it
it's just defining a set of initial
conditions and rules based on which
could behaves mm-hmm simulating the mind
requires you to have a little bit more
we're now in a little bit of a crazy lab
but it requires you to understand the
fundamentals of cognition perhaps of
consciousness of perception of
everything like that that's me that's
not created through some kind of
emergence from basic physics laws but
more requires you to actually understand
the fundamentals of the mind how about
if we said to simulate the brain the
brain rather than rather than the mind
the brain is just a big physical system
the universe is a giant physical system
I simulate the universe at the very
least you're going to have to simulate
the brains as well as all the other
physical systems within it and you know
it's not obvious there's that the
problems are any worse for the for the
brain than for its particularly complex
physical system but if we can simulate
arbitrary physical systems we can
simulate brains there is this further
question of whether when you simulate a
brain will that bring along all the
features of the mind with it like will
you get my consciousness will you get
thinking will you get free will and so
on and that's that's something
philosophers ever have argued over for
four years my own view is if you see if
you simulate the brain well enough that
will also simulate the mind but yeah
there's plenty of people who would say
no you'd merely get like a zombie system
a simulation of a brain without any true
consciousness but for you you put
together a brain the consciousness comes
with it arise yeah I don't think it's
obvious that's your intuition my view is
roughly that yeah what is responsible
for consciousness it's in the patents of
information processing and so on rather
than say the biology that it's made of
there's certainly plenty of people out
there who think consciousness has to be
say biological so if you merely
replicate the patterns of information
processing in a non-biological substrate
you'll miss what's crucial for
consciousness I mean I think just don't
think there's any particular reason to
think that biology is special here you
can imagine substituting the biology for
non biological systems a silicon
circuits that play the same role the
behavior will continue to be the same
and you know I think just the key about
what is the true I when I think about
the connection the isomorphisms between
consciousness and the brain the deepest
connections to me seemed to connect
consciousness to patterns of information
processing not specific biology so I at
least adopted as my working hypothesis
that basically it's the computation and
the information that matters for
consciousness the same time we don't
understand consciousness it should be
wrong so the computation the flow the
processing manipulation of information
the the process is where the
consciousness the software is where the
consciousness comes from not the
hardware roughly the software yeah the
patterns of information processing at
least in the in the hardware which we
could view as as software it may not be
some of you just like program and load
and erase and so on and the way we can
with ordinary software but it's
something at the level of information
processing rather than have a level of
implementation so on that what do you
think of the experience of self just the
experience of the world in a virtual
world in virtual reality is it possible
that we can create sort of offsprings of
our consciousness by existing in a
virtual world long enough so yeah ok can
we be conscious in in the same kind of
deep way that we are in this real world
by hanging out in a virtual world
yeah well the kind of virtual worlds we
have now or you know or interesting but
limited in certain ways in particular
they
relying on us having a brain and so on
which is outside the virtual world maybe
I'll strap on my VR headset I'll just
hang out in a in a virtual world on a on
a screen but my brain and then the
physical my physical environment might
be simulated if I'm in a virtual world
but right now there's no attempt to
simulate my brain I might Hank there
might be some non player characters and
these are in these virtual worlds that
have simulated cognitive systems of
certain kinds that dictate their
behavior but you know mostly they're
pretty simple right now I mean some
people are trying to combine put a bit
of AI and then non-player characters to
make them to make them them smarter but
for now inside virtual world the actual
thinking is interestingly distinct from
the physics of those virtual worlds in a
way actually I like to think this is
kind of reminiscent of the way that
Descartes thought our physical world was
there's physics and there's the mind and
they're separate now we now we think the
mind is somehow somehow connected to
physics pretty deeply but in these
virtual worlds there's a physics of a
virtual world and then there's this
brain which is totally outside the
virtual world that controls it and
interacts if when anyone anyone
exercises agency in a video game and you
know that's actually somebody outside
the virtual world moving a controller
controlling the interaction of things
inside the virtual world so right now in
virtual worlds the mind is somehow
outside the world but you could imagine
in the future once we get once we have
developed serious AI artificial general
intelligence and so on then we could
come to virtual worlds which have enough
sophistication you could actually
simulate a brain or have a genuine AGI
which were then presumably be able to
act in equally sophisticated ways maybe
even more sophisticated ways inside the
virtual world to how it might in the
physical world and then the question is
going to come along that would be kind
of a VR into a virtual world internal
intelligence and then the question is
could they have consciousness experience
intelligence free will yes all the
things that we have and again my view is
I don't see why not
to linger in a little bit
I find virtual reality really incredibly
powerful just even the crude virtual
reality we have now perhaps there's a
there's a psychological effects that's
makes some people more amenable to
virtual worlds and others but I find
myself wanting to stay in virtual worlds
for free yes with a headset or on a
desktop no with a headset really
interesting because I I am totally
addicted yet using the internet and
things on a on a desktop but when it
comes to VR for the headset I don't
typically use it for more than 10 or 20
minutes there's something just slightly
aversive about it I find so I don't
right now even though I have oculus rift
an oculus quest an HTC vive and Samsung
listen that I want to stay in now for
extended periods use you actually find
yourself the something about him it's a
both a combination of just imagination
and considering the possibilities of
where this goes in in the future it
feels like I want to almost prepare my
brain for like it I want to explore sort
of Disneyland when it's first being
built in the early days yeah and it
feels like I'm walking around almost
imagining the possibilities and
something through that process allows my
mind to really enter into that world but
you say that the brain is external to
that virtual world it is strictly
speaking true but if you're in VR and
you do brain surgery on an avatar and
you can open up that skull what are you
gonna find sorry nothing there nothing
the brain is elsewhere you don't think
it's possible to kind of separate them
and I don't mean in a sense like decart
like a hard separation but basically do
you think it's possible with the brain
outside of the virtual grid when you're
wearing a headset create a new
consciousness for prolonged periods of
time really feel like really experience
forget that human brain is outside so
this is okay this is gonna be the case
where the brain is still outside still
outside but could living in the VR I
mean I mean we already find this right
with video games
exactly completely immersive and you get
taken up by living in those worlds and
it becomes your reality for a while so
they're not completely immersive it's
very immersive you don't you don't
forget the external world no exactly so
if that's what I'm asking yeah it's
almost possible to really forget the
external world really really immerse
yourself what to forget completely why
would we forget you know we got pretty
good memories maybe you can stop paying
attention to the external world but you
know that this already happens a lot I
go to work and maybe I'm not paying
attention to my home life if I go to s I
go to a movie and I'm immersed in that
so that degree of emotion absolutely but
we still have the capacity to remember
it to completely forget the external
world I'm thinking that would probably
take some I don't know some pretty
serious drugs or something to make your
s but it's to make your brain do that
possible so I mean I guess I'm getting
at is consciousness a truly a property
that's tied to the the physical brain or
can it can you create sort of different
offspring copies of consciousness is
based on the worlds that you enter well
the way we're doing it now at least with
a standard VR there's just one brain
interact for the physical world plays a
video game puts on a video headset
interacts with this virtual world and I
think we typically say there's one
consciousness here that nonetheless
undergoes different environments takes
on different characters you know in
different environments this is already
something that happens in the non
virtual world you know I might interact
one way in my home life work life social
life and so on so at the very least that
will happen in a in a virtual world very
naturally people might people have very
people sometimes adopt the character of
avatars very different from themselves
maybe even a different gender or
different race different social
background
so that much is certainly possible I
would see that as a single consciousness
is singing on different personas if you
want literal splitting of consciousness
into multiple copies I think it's gonna
take something more radical than that
like maybe you can run different
simulations of your brain in different
realities and then expose them to
different histories and then you know
you just put yourself into 10 different
simulated copies which then undergo
different environments and then
ultimately do become 10 very different
consciousness maybe that could happen
but now we're not talking about
something that's possible in the near
term we're gonna have to have brain
simulations and AGI for that to happen
got it so before any of that happens
it's fundamentally you see it as a
singular consciousness even though it's
experiencing different environments
which are not it's still connected to
same set of memories same set of
experiences and therefore one sort of
joint conscious system yeah or at least
no more multiple than the kind of
multiple consciousness that we get from
and have inhabiting different
environments and in a non virtual world
so you said as a child you were a music
color Senna famously synesthete so we're
songs had colors for you
so what songs had what colors you know
this is funny um I didn't paint much
attention to this at the time but I've
listened to a piece of music and I'd get
some kind of imagery of a of a kind of a
kind of color of the wid thing is mostly
they were okay murky dark greens and
olive browns and the colors went all
that interesting I don't know what the
reason is I mean my theory is that maybe
it's like different cords and tones
provided different colors and the old
tended to get mixed together into these
somewhat uninteresting browns and greens
but every now and then there'd be
something that had a really pure color
so this just a few that I did I remember
it was a here there and everywhere by
the Beatles was bright red and has this
you know very distinctive tonality and
it's chord structure at the at the
beginnings of that
right red it was a song by the Alan
Parsons Project called ammonia Avenue
that was it was kind of a pure a pure
blue anyway I've got no idea how would
this happen didn't even pay that much
attention until it went away when I was
about 20 this synesthesia often goes
away so is it purely just the perception
of a particular color or was there a
positive or negative experience with it
like was blue associate with a positive
and red with a negative or is it simply
the perception of color associate with
some characteristic of the song for me I
don't remember a lot of association with
with emotion or what the value was just
this kind of weird and interesting fact
I mean at the beginning I thought this
was something that happened to everyone
songs have colors maybe I mentioned it
once or twice and people said no no ed
it was like I thought was kind of cool
when there was one that had one of these
especially pure colors but only much
later once I became a grad student
thinking about the mind that I read
about this phenomenon called synesthesia
it's like hey that's what I had and now
I occasionally talk about it in my
classes in intro class and still happens
sometimes a student comes up and says
hey I have that I never knew about that
I never knew it had a name you said they
want to run away at age 20 or so and the
you have a journal entry from around and
saying songs don't have colors anymore
what happened what happened yeah I was
definitely sad that it was gone in
retrospect there's like hey that's cool
the colors have gone yeah do you can you
think about that for a little bit do you
miss those experiences because it's a
fundamentally different sets of
experiences that you no longer have
mm-hmm or deed or is it just a nice
thing to have had you don't see them as
that fundamentally different than you
visiting a new country and experiencing
new environments I guess for me when I
had these experiences they were somewhat
marginal they were like a little bonus
kind of experience I know there are
people have much more serious forms of
synesthesia than this for whom it's
absolutely central to their lives I know
people who when they experience new
people they have colors maybe they have
tastes
and so on every time they see writing it
has it has colors some people whenever
they hear music it's got a it's got a
certain really rich color pattern and
you know for some synesthetes it's
absolutely central I think if they lost
it they'd be devastated again for me it
was a very very mild form of synesthesia
it's like yeah it's like those
interesting experiences yeah you know
you might get under different altered
states of consciousness and and so on
it's kind of cool but you know not
necessarily the single most important
experiences in your life so let's try to
go to the very simplest question the
events are bring you time but perhaps
the simplest things can help us reveal
even in time some some new ideas so what
in your view is consciousness what is
qualia what is the hard problem of
consciousness consciousness I mean the
word has used many ways but the kind of
consciousness that I'm interested in is
basically subjective experience what it
feels like from the inside to be a human
being or any other conscious being I
mean there's something it's like to be
me right now I have visual images that I
am experiencing I'm hearing my voice
I've got maybe some emotional tone I've
got a stream of thoughts running through
my head these are all things that I
experience from the first-person point
of view of sometimes called this the
inner movie in the mind it's not a
perfect it's not a perfect metaphor it's
not like a movie in every ways and in
every way and it's very rich but yeah
it's just direct subjective experience
and I call that consciousness or
sometimes philosophers use the word
qualia which you suggested people tend
to use the word qualia for things like
the qualities of things like colors
redness the experience of redness versus
the experience of greenness the
experience of one taste or one smell
versus another the experience of the
quality of pain and a lot of
consciousness is the experience of those
of those those qualities of
consciousness is big
the entirety of any kinds of extraneous
of thinking is not obviously qualia it's
not like specific qualities like redness
or greenness but still I'm thinking
about my hometown I'm thinking about
what I'm gonna do later on maybe there's
still something running through my my
head which is subjective experience
maybe it goes beyond those qualities or
qualia philosophers sometimes use the
word phenomenal consciousness for
consciousness in this sense I mean
people also talk about access
consciousness being able to access
information and your mind
reflective consciousness being able to
think about yourself but it looks like
the really mysterious one the one that
really gets people going is phenomenal
consciousness the fact that all this the
fact that the subjective experience and
all this feels like something at all and
then the hard problem is how is it that
why is it that there is phenomenal
consciousness at all and how is it that
physical processes in a brain could give
you subjective experience it looks like
try on the face of it you have all this
big complicated physical system in a
brain running and without a given
subjective experience at all and yet we
do have subjective experience so the
hard problem is just explained that
explain how that comes about we haven't
been able to build machines work a red
light goes on that says it's not
conscious so how does how do we actually
create that or how do humans do it and
how do we ourselves do it we do every
now and then create machines that can do
this you know we create babies yes that
our that our conscious take out these
brains asbestos brain does produce
consciousness but even me even though we
can't create it we still don't
understand when it happens maybe
eventually we'll be able to create
machines which as a matter of fact AI
machines which as a matter of fact our
conscious but that won't necessarily
make the hard problem go away any more
than it does with babies because we
still want to know how and why is it
that these processes give you
consciousness you know you just made me
realize for a second maybe it's a
totally dumb realization but
nevertheless that it's a useful way to
think about
the creation consciousness is looking at
a baby so that there's a certain point
at which that baby is not conscious
mm-hmm something sort of the baby starts
from maybe I don't I don't know from a
few cells right there's a certain point
at which it becomes consciousness
arrives it's conscious of course we
can't know exactly that line but that's
a useful idea that we do we do create
consciousness again a really dumb thing
for me to say but it not until now that
I realized we do engineer consciousness
we we get to watch the process happen we
don't know which point it happens or
where it is but you know we do see the
birth of consciousness yeah I mean
there's a question of course is whether
babies are conscious when they're born
and it used to be it seems at least some
people thought they weren't which is why
they didn't give anesthetics to newborn
babies when they circumcised them and so
now people think oh that's you know be
incredibly cruel yeah of course of
course babies feel pain and now the
dominant view is that the babies can
feel pain I actually my partner of
Claudia works on this whole issue of
whether there's consciousness and babies
and of what kind and she certainly
thinks that newborn babies you know come
into the world with some degree of
consciousness because then you could
just extend the question backwards to
fetuses suddenly are too politically
controversial exactly territory but you
know there the question also arises in
the animal kingdom you know what where
does consciousness start or stop is
there a line in the animal kingdom where
you know the first conscious organisms
aren't it's interesting over time people
are becoming more and more liberal about
ascribing consciousness to animals
people used to think maybe only mammals
could be conscious now most people seem
to think show a fish are conscious they
can feel pain and now we're arguing over
insects you'll find people out there who
say plants have some degree of
consciousness so you know who knows
where it's gonna end the far end of this
chain is the view that every physical
system has some degree of consciousness
philosophers call that pen sarcasm
you know I take that view I mean that's
a fascinating way to view reality so you
could talk about if you can linger on
pan psychism for a little bit what what
does it mean it's not just plants are
conscious I mean it's that consciousness
is a fundament the fabric of reality
what does that mean to you how do we
supposed to think about that
well we're used to the idea that some
things in the world are fundamental
right in physics like why we take things
like space or time or space-time mass
charge as fundamental properties of the
universe you don't reduce them to
something simpler you take those for
granted you've got some laws that
connect them here is how mass in space
and time evolved theories like
relativity or quantum mechanics or some
future theory that will unify them both
but everyone says you got to take some
things as fundamental and if you can't
explain one thing in terms of the
previous fundamental things you have to
expand maybe something like this happen
with Maxwell ended up with fundamental
principles of electromagnetism and took
charge as fundamental because turned out
that was the best way to explain it so I
at least take seriously the possibility
something like that could happen with
consciousness take it as a fundamental
property like space time and mass
instead of trying to explain
consciousness wholly in terms of the
evolution of space-time and and mass and
so on take it as a primitive and then
connected to everything else by some
fundamental laws because I mean there's
basic there's this basic problem that
the physics we have now looks great for
solving the easy problems of
consciousness which are all about
behavior strike they give us a
complicated structure and dynamics they
tell us how things are going to behave
what kind of observable behavior they're
produced which is great for the problems
of explaining how we walk and how we
talk and so on those are the easy
problems of consciousness but the hard
problem was this problem about
subjective experience just doesn't look
like that kind of problem about
structure or dynamics how things behave
so it's hard to see
existing physics is going to give you a
full explanation of that certainly
trying to get a physics view of
consciousness yes there there has to be
a connecting point and it could be at
the very exome attic at the very
beginning level but first of all there's
a crazy idea that sort of everything has
properties of consciousness there's a
would at that point the word
consciousness is already beyond the
region of our current understanding like
far because it's so far from at least
for me maybe you can correct me it's far
from the experience and the experiences
that we have that I have as a human
being it to say that everything is
cautious that means that means there
that basically another way to put that
if if that's true then we understand
almost nothing about that ask
fundamental aspect of the world how do
you feel about saying an ant is
conscious to get the same reaction to
the head or is that something you can
understand I can understand ant I can't
understand an atom applying chol plant
so I'm comfortable with living things on
earth mm-hmm being cautious because
there's some kind of agency where
there's similar size to me and they can
be born and they can die and that is
understandable intuitively of course you
anthropomorphize you put yourself in the
place of the plant but I can understand
it I mean I'm I'm not like I don't
believe actually that plants are
conscious of that plant suffer but I can
understand that kind of belief that kind
of idea how do you feel how do you feel
about robots like the kind of robots we
have now if I told you like that you
know a Roomba at some degree of
consciousness or some you know deep
neural network I could understand that a
Roomba has coasters I just had spent all
day at iRobot
I and I mean I personally love robots
and have a deep connection with robots
so I can I also probably enterpreneur
Faiz them there's something about the
physical object so this difference than
a neural network then you'll network
running a software to me the physical
object something about the human
experience allows me to really see that
physical object is an entity and if it
moves and moves in a way that it there's
a like I didn't program it where it
feels that it's acting based on its own
perception and yes self awareness and
consciousness even if it's a Roomba then
you start to assign it some agency some
consciousness so but to say that Pan
psychism that conscious is a fundamental
property of reality is a much bigger
statement mm-hmm that it it's like
Turtles all the way - yeah every is it
doesn't end and the whole thing is so
like how I know it's full mystery but if
you can linger on it and I go how would
it how do you think about reality if
consciousness is a fundamental part of
its fabric the way you get there some
thinking can we explain consciousness
given the existing fundamentals and then
if you current is at least right now it
looks like then you've got to add
something it doesn't follow that you
have to add consciousness here's another
interesting possibility is we'll add
something else that's called a proto
consciousness or x-ray and then it turns
out space-time mass plus X will somehow
collectively give you the possibility
for for consciousness we don't rule out
that view either I call that pan proto
psychism because maybe there's a some
other property proto consciousness at
the bottom level and if you can't
imagine there's actually genuine
consciousness at the bottom level I
think we should be open to the idea
there's this other thing X maybe we
can't imagine this somehow gives you
consciousness but if we are not playing
along with the idea that there really is
genuine consciousness at the
level of course this is gonna be way out
and speculative but you know at least in
say if it was classical physics then
we'd have to end up saying well every
little half every with you a bunch of
particles in space-time each of these
particles has some kind of consciousness
whose structure mirrors maybe their
physical properties like its mass charge
its velocity and so on the structure of
its consciousness would roughly
correspond to that and the physical
interactions between particles I mean
there's this old worried about physics I
mentioned this before in this issue
about the manifest image we don't really
find out about the intrinsic nature of
things physics tells us about how a
particle relates to other particles and
interacts it doesn't tell us about what
the particle is in itself that was can't
sing in itself so here's a view the
nature in itself of a particle is
something mental a particle is actually
a conscious a little conscious subject
with with properties of its
consciousness to correspond to its
physical properties the laws of physics
are actually ultimately relating these
properties of conscious subjects on this
view a Newtonian world actually would be
a vast collection of little conscious
subjects at the bottom level way way
simpler than we are without free will or
rationality or anything like that but
that's what the universe would be like
of course that's a vastly speculative
you know what no particular reason think
is correct furthermore non Newtonian
physics say a quantum mechanical wave
function
suddenly a sort of difference on a vast
collection of conscious subjects may be
the is ultimately one big wave function
for the whole universe corresponding to
that might be something more like as a
single conscious mind whose structure
corresponds to the structure of the wave
function people sometimes call this
cosmos sarcasm and now of course we're
in the realm of extremely speculative
philosophy there's no direct evidence
for this but yeah but if you want a
picture of what that universe would be
like think yeah giant cosmic mind with
enough richness and structure among it
to replicate all the structure of
physics
I think there
I am at the level of particles and with
quantum mechanics at the level of the
wavefunction it's a it's kind of an
exciting beautiful possibility of course
way out of reach of physics currently it
is interesting that some neuroscientists
our act begins to take pen psychism
seriously you find consciousness even in
very in very simple systems so for
example the integrated information
theory of consciousness a lot of
neuroscientists are taking seriously
actually I just got this new book by
Christophe cook just came in the feeling
of life itself my consciousness is
widespread but can't be computed he
likes he basically endorses a pen Sarkis
view where you get consciousness with
the degree of information processing or
integrated information processing in a
simple in a system and even very very
simple systems like a couple of
particles will have some degree of this
so he ends up with some degree of
consciousness in all matter and the
claim is that this theory can actually
explain a bunch of stuff about the
connection between the brain and
consciousness now that's very
controversial I think it's very very
early days in the science of
consciousness it's interesting the it's
not just philosophy that might lead you
in this direction but there are ways of
thinking quasi scientifically that leads
you there too
but maybe different than pen psychism
what do you think so Allen Watts has
this quote I'd like to ask you about the
quote is through our eyes the universe
is perceiving itself through our ears
universe is listening to its harmonies
we are the witnesses to which the
universe becomes conscious of his glory
of its magnificence so that's not pants
psychism do you think that we are
essentially the tools the senses the
universe created to be conscious of
itself it's an interesting idea of
course if you went for the giant cosmic
mind view then the universe was
conscious all along it didn't need us
we're just little components of the
universal consciousness likewise if you
believe in penstock ism
then there was some little degree of
consciousness at the bottom level all
along and we were just more complex form
of consciousness so I think maybe the
quote you mentioned works better if
you're not a pen Sarkis you're not a
Cosmo Sarkis do you think consciousness
just exists at this at this intermediate
level and of course that's the Orthodox
view that you would say is the the
common useless is your own view with pan
psychism a rarer view I think it's
generally regarded certainly as a
speculative view held by a fairly small
minority of at least theorists
philosophers most philosophers and most
scientists who think about consciousness
are not pants artists there's been a bit
of a movement in that direction the last
10 years or so it seems to be quite
popular especially among the younger
generation but it's still very
definitely a minority view many people
think is totally batshit crazy to use
the technical term the philosophical ter
so the Orthodox view I think is still
consciousness is something that humans
have and some good number of non-human
animals have and maybe a eyes might have
one day but it's restricted on that view
then there was no consciousness at the
start of universe there may be none at
the end but it is this thing which
happened at some point in the history of
the universe consciousness developed and
yes it's on that's a very amazing event
on this view because many people are
inclined to think consciousness is what
somehow gives meaning to our lives
without consciousness
there'd be no meaning no true value no
good versus bad and so on so with the
advent of consciousness suddenly the
universe went from meaningless to
somehow meaningful why did this happen I
guess the quote you mentioned was
somehow this was somehow destined to
happen because the universe needed to
have consciousness within it to have
value and have meaning and maybe you
could combine that with a theistic view
or a teleological view the universe was
inexorably evolving towards
consciousness actually my colleague here
at NYU Tom Nagel wrote a book called
mind and cosmos a few years ago where we
are
for this teleological view of evolution
toward consciousness saying this let the
problems for Darwinism it's got a
mountain you know so it's very very
controversial most people didn't agree I
don't myself agree with this
teleological view but it is a it's at
least a beautiful speculative view love
the of the cosmos what do you think
people experience what do they seek when
they believe in God from this kind of
perspective mm-hmm I'm not an expert on
thinking about God and religion I'm not
myself religious at all when people sort
of pray communicate with God word at
which whatever form I'm not speaking to
sort of the practices and the rituals
non religion I mean the actual
experience of that people really have a
deep connection of God in some cases mhm
what do you think that experience is
it's so common at least throughout the
history of civilization that it seems
like we seek that at the very least it's
an interesting conscious experience that
people have when they experience
religious or or prayer and so on
neuroscientists have tried to examine
what bits of the brain are active and so
on but yeah that is this deeper question
of what is what are people looking for
when they're doing this and like I said
but no real expertise on this but it
does seem the one thing people are after
is a sense of meaning and value a sense
of connection to something greater than
themselves that will give their lives
meaning and value and maybe the thought
is if there is a God and God somehow is
a universal consciousness who has
invested this universe with meaning and
some our connection to God might give
your life meaning I got so I can kind of
see the see the attractions of that but
it still makes me wonder why is it
exactly that a universal consciousness
you know God would be needed to give the
lot to give the world
if I mean if universal consciousness can
give the world meaning
why can't local consciousness give the
world meaning to so I think my
consciousness gives my world is the
meaning is the origin of meaning vary
your world yeah I experience things as
good or bad happy sad interesting
important so my consciousness invests
this world with meaning without any
consciousness maybe it would be a bleak
meaningless universe but I don't see why
I need someone else's consciousness or
even God's consciousness to give this
this universe meaning here we are local
creatures with our own subjective
experiences I think we can give the
universe meaning ourselves so I mean
maybe just some people that feels
inadequate yeah
our own local consciousness is somehow
too puny and insignificant to invest any
of this with cosmic significance and
maybe God gives you a sense of cosmic
significance but I'm just speculating
here so the you know it's a really
interesting idea that consciousness is
the thing that makes life meaningful if
you could maybe just just briefly
explore that for a second so I suspect
just from listening to you know you mean
in an almost trivial sense just the
day-to-day experiences of life have
because of you attached identity to it
mm-hmm
they become oh I guess I want to ask
something I I would always wanted to ask
College it Rock world renowned
philosopher what is the meaning of life
but I suspect you don't mean
consciousness gives any kind of greater
meaning to it all yeah and more to
day-to-day but is there greater meaning
to it all I think life has meaning for
us because we are conscious
so without consciousness no meaning
consciousness invests our life with
meaning so consciousness is the source
of my view of the meaning of life but I
wouldn't say consciousness
self is the meaning of life I'd say
what's meaningful in life is basically
what we find meaningful what we
experience as meaningful so if you find
meaning and fulfillment and value and
say intellectual work like understanding
then that's your that's a very
significant part of the meaning of life
for you if you find it in social
connections or in raising a family and
that's the meaning of life for you the
meaning kind of comes from what you
value as a conscious creature so I think
there's no you on this view there's no
universal solution
you know Universal answer to the
question what is the meaning of life the
meaning of life is where you find it as
a conscious creature but it's
consciousness that somehow makes value
possible experiencing some things as
good or as bad or as meaningful
something comes from within
consciousness so you think consciousness
is a crucial component ingredient of
having given assigning value to things I
mean it's kind of a fairly strong
intuition that without consciousness
there wouldn't really be any value if we
just had a purely a universe of
unconscious creatures would anything be
better or worse than anything else
certainly when it comes to ethical
dilemmas you know you know about the
older the old trolley problem do you you
kill one person or do you switch to the
other track to kill kill Fievel I got a
variant on this their zombie trolley
problem where there's one conscious
being on on one track and five humanoid
zombies let's make them robots yeah who
are not who are not conscious on the on
the other track do you given that choice
you kill the one conscious being or the
five unconscious robots most people have
a fairly clear intuition here yeah kill
the kill the unconscious beings because
they basically they don't have a
meaningful life they're not really
persons conscious beings of course we
don't have good intuition about
something like an unconscious being so
in philosophical terms you refer to as
Azzam
mm-hmm it's a useful thought experiment
construction in philosophical terms but
we don't yet have them so that's kind of
what we may be able to create with
robots and I don't necessarily know what
that even means
yes merely hypothetical for now they're
just a thought experiment they may never
be possible I mean the extreme case of a
zombie is a being which is physically
functionally behaviorally identical to
me but not conscious that's a mirror I
don't think that could ever be built in
this universe the question is just could
we does that hypothetically make sense
that's kind of a useful contrast class
to raise questions like why aren't we
zombies how does it come about that
we're conscious and we're not like that
but there were less extreme versions of
this like robots which are maybe not
physically identical to us maybe not
even functionally identical to us maybe
they've got a different architecture but
they can do a lot of sophisticated
things maybe carry on a conversation but
they're not conscious that's not so far
out we've got simple computer systems
these tending in that direction now and
presumably this is gonna get more and
more sophisticated over years to come
where we may have some pretty it's least
quite straightforward to conceive of
some pretty sophisticated robot systems
that can use language and be fairly high
functioning without consciousness at all
then I stipulate that I mean we've cost
there's this tricky question of how you
would know whether they're conscious but
let's say we've somehow solved that and
we know that these high-functioning
robots aren't conscious then the
question is do they have moral status
does it matter how we treat them like
what is moral status means does
basically society can they suffer
doesn't matter how we treat them I would
for example if we if I mistreat this
glass this cup by uh by shattering it
then that's bad well why is it bad that
was kind of make a mess it's gonna be
annoying for me in my partner and so
it's not bad for the cup no one would
say the cup itself has moral state
hey you you heard the cup and that's
that's doing it a moral harm
likewise plants will again if they're
not conscious most people think if by
operating a plant you're not harming it
but if a being is conscious on the other
hand then you are harming it so Siri or
I dare not say the name of Alexa anyway
we're so we don't think we're we're
morally harming Alexa by turning her off
or disconnecting her or even destroying
her whether it's the system or the or
the underlying software system because
we don't really think she's conscious on
the other hand you moved to it like the
the disembodied being in the moving in
the movie her Samantha I guess she was
kind of presented as conscious and then
if you if you destroyed her you'd
certainly be committing a serious harm
so I think how strong senses if a being
is conscious and can undergo subjective
experiences that are matters morally how
we treat them so if a robot is conscious
it matters but if a robot is not
conscious then they basically just meet
or a machine and it and it and it
doesn't matter so I think at least maybe
how we think about this stuff is
fundamentally wrong but I think a lot of
people to think about this stuff
seriously including people to think
about say the moral treatment of animals
and so on come to the view that
consciousness is ultimately kind of the
line between systems that where we have
to take them into account in thinking
morally about how we act and systems for
which we don't and I think I've seen you
the writer talked about the
demonstration of consciousness from a
system like that from a system like Alex
or a conversational agent that is what
you would be looking for it's kind of at
the very basic level for the system to
have an awareness that I'm just a
program and yet why do I experience this
or not to have that experience but to
communicate that to you so that's what
us humans would sound like if you all of
a sudden woke up one day
like Kafka right in the body of a bug or
something but in a computer you all
sudden realize you don't have a body and
yet you would feel what you're feeling
you would probably say those kinds of
things mm-hmm
so do you think a system essentially
becomes conscious by convincing us that
it's conscious hmm
through the words that I just mentioned
so by being confused about the fact that
why am I having these experiences well
so basically I don't think this is what
makes your conscious but I do think
being puzzled about consciousness is a
very good sign that a system is
conscious so if I encountered a robot
that actually seemed to be genuinely
puzzled by its own mental states and
saying yeah I have all these weird
experiences and I don't see how to
explain them I know I'm a just a set of
silicon circuits but I don't see how
that would give you my consciousness I
would at least take that as some
evidence that there's some consciousness
going on there I don't think a system
needs to be puzzled about consciousness
to be conscious many people are puzzled
by their consciousness animals don't
seem to be puzzled at all I still think
they're conscious but I think that's a
requirement on consciousness but I do
think if we're looking for signs for
consciousness say in AI systems one of
the things will help convince me that an
AI system is consciousness if it shows
signs of it if it shows signs of
introspectively recognizing something
like consciousness and finding this
philosophically puzzling and the way
that the way that that we do the
incision interesting thought though
because a lot of people sort of would at
the shower level criticize the Turing
test for language that it's essentially
what I heard like Dan Dennett criticized
it in this kind of way which is it's
really puts a lot of emphasis on lying
yeah and being able to being able to
imitate human beings yeah there's this a
there's this cartoon of the AI system
studying for the Turing test it's gotta
be this book called talk like a human
like man I don't have to waste my time
learning how to imitate humans
maybe the AI system is gonna be way
beyond the hard problem of consciousness
and it's gotta be this thing why do I
need to waste my time pretending that I
recognize the hard problem of
consciousness - in order for people to
recognize me as conscious yeah it just
feels like I guess the question is do
you think there's a we can never really
create a test for consciousness because
it feels like we're very human centric
and so the only way we would be
convinced that something is
consciousness but is basically the thing
demonstrates the illusion of
consciousness that we can never really
know whether it's conscious or not and
in fact that almost feels like it
doesn't matter them or does it still
matter to you that something is
conscious or it demonstrates
consciousness you still see that
fundamental distinction I think a lot of
people whether our system is conscious
or not matters hugely for many things
like how we treat it cannot suffer and
so on but still that leaves open the
question how can we ever know and it's
true that it's awfully hard to see how
we can know for sure
whether a system is conscious I suspect
that sociologically the thing that's
going to convince us that the system is
conscious is in part things like social
interaction conversation and so on where
they seem to be conscious they talk
about their conscious state so I just
talked about being happy or sad or
finding things meaningful or being in
pain that will tend to convince us if we
don't the system genuinely seems to be
conscious we don't treat it as such
eventually it's gonna seem like a
strange form of racism or speciesism or
somehow not to acknowledge them and
actually we believe that by the way I
believe that there is going to be
something akin to the civil rights
movement but for robots mm-hmm
I think the moment you have a Roomba say
please don't kick me that hurts just say
it yeah I think they will fundamentally
change the fabric
of our society I think you're probably
right although it's gonna be very tricky
because just say where we've got the
technology where these conscious beings
can just be moderated and multiplied by
the thousands by flicking a switch so
and the legal status is gonna be
different but ultimately the moral
status ought to be the same and yeah the
civil rights issue is gonna be a huge
mess so if one day somebody clones you
another very real possibility in fact I
find the conversation between two copies
of David Chalmers quite interesting
every thought he's not making any sense
so what do you think he would be
cautious I do think he would be
conscious I do think in some sense not
sure would be me there would be two
different beings at this point I think
they both be conscious and they both
have many of the same mental properties
I think they both you know way have the
same moral status it'll be wrong to hurt
either of them or they kill them and so
on still there's some sense in which
probably their legal status would have
to be different if I am the original and
that one's just a clone then you're
creating a clone of me presumably the
clone doesn't for example automatically
own the stuff that I own or you know
I've got a you know certain connect the
things that the people I interact with
my family my partner and so on and I'm
gonna somehow be connected to them in a
way in which the clone isn't so because
you came slightly first yeah but this
alone would argue yeah they have really
as much of a connection they have all
the memories of that connection then
away you might say it's kind of unfair
to discriminate against them but say
you've got an apartment that only one
person can live in or a partner who only
one person or why she didn't leave you
that's the original it's an interesting
philosophical question but you might say
because I actually have this history
if I am the same person there's a one
that came before and the clone is not
that I have this history that the clone
doesn't because there's also the
question isn't the clone the same person
- this is the question about personal
identity if I continue and I create a
clone over there I want to say this one
is me and this one is is someone else
but you could take the view that a clone
is equally me of course in a movie like
Star Trek where they have a
teletransport it basically creates
clones all the time they treat the
clones as if they're the original person
of course they destroy the original body
in Star Trek Isis there's only one left
around and only very occasionally two
things go wrong and you get two copies
of Captain Kirk it's somehow our legal
system at the very least is gonna have
to sort out some of these issues and
that maybe that's what's moral and watch
League what's legally acceptable are
gonna come apart what question would you
ask a clone of yourself yeah is there
something useful II you can find out
from him about the fundamentals of
cautiousness even I mean kind of in
principle I know that if it's a perfect
clone it's gonna behave just like me so
I'm not sure I'm gonna be able to I
could discover whether it's a perfect
clone by seeing whether it answers like
me but otherwise I know what I'm gonna
find is being which is just like me
except that it's just undergone this
great shock of discovering that it's a
clone so just so you woke me up tomorrow
and said hey Dave sorry to tell you this
but you're actually the clone and you
provided be really convincing evidence
should be the film of my being cloned
and then all wrapped here being here and
and waking up so you proved to me I'm a
criminal yeah okay I would find that
shocking and who knows how I would react
to this so so maybe by talking to the
clone I'd find something about my own
psychology but I can't find out so
easily like how I'd react upon
discovering that I'm a clone I could
certainly ask the clone if it's
conscious and what his consciousness is
like and so on but I guess I kind of
know if it's a perfect clone it's gonna
behave roughly like me of course at the
beginning there'll be a
question about whether a perfect clone
is possible so I may want to ask it lots
of questions to see if it's
consciousness and the way it talks about
is consciousness and the way it reacts
to things in general is like me and you
know that will occupy us for a it's a
basic unit unit testing in the early
model yeah so you so if it's a perfect
clone you say there's gonna be --have
exactly like you so that takes us to
freewill mmm-hmm is there a free will
are we able to make decisions that are
not predetermined from the initial
conditions in the universe you know
philosophers do this annoying thing of
saying it depends what you mean so in
this case yeah really depends on what
you mean by by freewill
if you mean something which was not
determined in advance could never have
been determined then I don't know we
have freewill
I mean there's quantum mechanics and
who's to say if that opens up some room
but I'm not sure we have freewill in
that sense I'm also not sure that's the
kind of freewill that really matters you
know what matters to us is being able to
do what we want and to create our own
futures we've got this distinction
between having our lives be under our
control and under someone else's control
method we've got the sense of actions
that we are responsible for versus ones
that were not I think you can make those
distinctions even in a deterministic
universe and this is what people call
the compatibilist view of freewill where
it's compatible with determinism I think
for many purposes the kind of freewill
that matters is something we can have in
a deterministic universe and I can't see
any reason in principle why an AI system
couldn't have freewill
of that kind if you mean super-duper
freewill the ability to violate the laws
of physics and doing things that
imprints of all could not be predicted I
don't know maybe no one has that kind of
freewill what's the connection between
the the reality of freewill and the
experience of it the subjective
experience in your view so how does
consciousness connect to this to the
experience
to the reality in the experience of
feels certainly true that when we make
decisions and when we choose and so on
we feel like we have an open future yes
feel like I could do this I could go
into philosophy or I could go into math
I could go to a movie tonight I could go
to restaurant so we experience these
things as if the future is open and
maybe we experience ourselves as
exerting a kind of effect on the future
that somehow picking out one path from
many paths were previously open and you
might think that actually if we're in a
deterministic universe there's a sense
in which objectively those paths weren't
really open all along but subjectively
they were open and that's I think that's
what really matters in making a
decisions were our experience of making
a decision as choosing a path for for
ourselves I mean in general our
introspective models of the mind I think
are generally very distorted
representations of the mind so it may
well be that our experience of our self
in making a decision experience of
what's going on doesn't terribly well
mirror what's uh what's going on I mean
you know maybe there are antecedents in
the brain way before anything came into
consciousness and and and so on
those aren't represented in our
introspective models so in general our
experience of our experience of
perception yes I experienced perceptual
image of the external world it's not a
terribly good model of what's actually
going on in the in my visual cortex and
so on which has all these layers and so
on it's just one little snapshot of of
one bit of that so in general yeah
introspective models are very over
oversimplified and it wouldn't be
surprising if that was true of free will
as well
this also incidentally can be applied to
consciousness itself there is this very
interesting view that consciousness
itself is an introspective illusion in
fact we're not conscious but we but
weeks the brain just has these
introspective models of itself or
oversimplifies everything and represents
itself as having these special
properties of consciousness thing it's a
really simple way to kind of keep track
of it so
and so on and then on The Illusionist
view yeah that's just a that's just an
illusion it was I find this view I find
it implausible I do find it very
attractive in some ways because it's
easy to tell some story about how the
brain would create introspective models
of its own consciousness of its own free
will as a way of simplifying yourself I
mean it's similar way when we perceive
the external world we perceive it as
having these colors that maybe it
doesn't really have because that's a
really useful way of keeping tracks of
keeping track did you say that you find
it not very plausible because I I
thought I find it both plausible and
attractive in some sense because it I
mean that's that kind of view is one
that has the minimum amount of mystery
around it
you can kind of understand that kind of
view everything else says we don't
understand so much of this picture you
know it is four it is very attractive I
recently wrote an article all about this
kind of issue called the meta problem of
consciousness the hard problem is how
does the brain give you consciousness
the meta problem is why are we puzzled
by the hard problem of consciousness and
because you know I'll being puzzled by
it that's ultimately a bit of behavior
we might be able to explain that bit of
behavior as one of the easy problems
consciousness so maybe there'll be some
computational model that explains why
we're puzzled by consciousness the meta
problem has come up with that model and
I've been thinking about that a lot
lately there's some interesting stories
you can tell about why the right kind of
computational system might develop these
introspective models of itself that are
attributed itself these special
properties so that that meta problem is
a resource fasten gram program for
everyone and then if you've got
attraction to sort of simple views
desert landscapes and so on then you can
go all the way with what people call
illusionism and say in fact
consciousness itself is not real what
Israel is just these these these
introspective models we have that tell
us that we're conscious so the view is
very simple very attractive very
powerful the trouble is of course it has
to say that deep down consciousness is
not real we're not actually experiencing
right now and it looks like it's just
contradicting a fundamental datum of our
existence and this is why most people
find this view crazy just as they find
Pam sake as I'm crazy in one way people
find illusionism crazy in another way
but it's I mean but it so yes it has to
deny this fundamental datum of our
existence now and the view that makes
the view soar frankly unbelievable for
most people on the other hand the view
develop right might be able to explain
why we find it unbelievable
because these modal's are so deeply hop
right into our head and they're all
integrated so it's not you can't escape
that the the illusion and as the crazy
possibility is it possible that the
entirety of the universe our planet all
the people in New York all the organisms
on our planet the including me here
today are not real in in that sense
they're all part of an illusion inside
of Dave Chalmers whose head I think all
this could be a simulation no but not
just a simulation yeah because the
simulation kind of is outside of you I
mean what if it's all an illusion they
yes a dream that you are experiencing
that's it's all in your mind
right thank you is that can you take
illusionism that far well there's
illusionism about the external world and
illusionism about consciousness and
these might go in respective different
illusionism about the external world
kind of takes you back to Descartes and
yet could all this be produced by an
evil demon they caught himself also had
the dream argument he said how do you
know you're not dreaming right now how
do you know this is not an amazing dream
and it's at least a possibility that
yeah this could be some super duper
complex dream in the next universe up I
guess so my attitude is that just as
when a car
thought that if the evil demon was doing
it it's not real a lot of people these
days say if a simulation is doing it
it's not real as I was saying before I
think even if it's a simulation that
doesn't stop this is being real it just
tells us what the world is made of black
white if it's a dream it could turn out
that all this is like my dream created
by my brain and the next universe up my
own view is that wouldn't stop this
physical world from being real would
turn out this Cup at the most
fundamental level was made of a bit of
say my consciousness in the Dreaming
mind at the next level up maybe that
would give you a kind of weird kind of
pants sarcasm about reality but it
wouldn't show that the cup isn't real
but just tell us it's ultimately made of
processes in my dreaming mind so I'd
resist the idea that if the physical
world is a dream then it's an illusion
then it's right by the way perhaps you
have an interesting thought about it why
is there cards demon or genius
considered evil what couldn't have been
a benevolent one I had the same powers
yeah I mean Dakota the Malheur genie the
evil genie or evil genius malign I guess
was the word but it's interesting
question I mean a later philosophy
Berkeley said no in fact all this is
done by God God actually supply supplies
you all of these all of these
perceptions and ideas and that's how
physical reality is sustained
interestingly Barclays God is doing
something that doesn't look so different
from what des cartes evil demon was
doing it's just that they can't thought
it was deception and Berkeley thought it
was not and I'm I'm actually most
sympathetic to Berkeley here yeah this
evil demon may be trying to deceive you
but I think okay well the evil demon may
just be under the working under a false
philosophical theory is deceiving you
it's wrong it's like there's machines on
the matrix they thought they were
deceiving you that all this stuff is
real I think know if we're in a matrix
it's all still it's all still real
yeah the the philosopher ok booster I
had a nice story about this about 50
years ago about dick Hart's evil demon
where he said this demon spends all its
time trying to fool people but fails
because I'm how old demon ends up doing
is constructing realities for 4 people
so yeah I think that maybe if it's a
very natural to take this view that if
we're in a simulation or or evil demon
scenario or something then none of this
is real but I think it may be ultimately
a philosophical mistake especially if
you take on board sort of the view of
reality well what matters to reality is
really its structure something like its
mathematical structure and so on which
seems to be the view that a lot of
people take from contemporary physics
and looks like you can find all that
mathematical structure in a simulation
maybe even in a dream and so on so as
long as that structure is real I would
say that's enough for the physical world
to be real yeah the physical world may
turn out to be somewhat more intangible
than we had thought and have a
surprising nature of it
we're already gotten very used to that
from for modern science see you've kind
of looted that you don't have to have
consciousness for high levels of
intelligence but to create truly general
intelligent systems ági systems at human
level intelligence and perhaps
superhuman level intelligence you've
talked about that it you feel like that
kind of thing might be very far away but
nevertheless one we reached that point
do you think consciousness from an
engineering perspective is needed or at
least highly beneficial for creating in
the a GI system yeah no one knows what
consciousness is for functionally so
right now there's no specific thing we
can point to and say you need
consciousness for that still my
inclination is to believe that in
principle AGI is possible at the very
least I don't see why someone couldn't
simulate a brain ultimately have a
computational system that produces all
of our behavior and if that's possible
I'm sure vastly many other computational
systems of equal or greater
fists ocation are possible for all of
our cognitive functions and more my
inclination is to think that once you've
got all these cognitive functions you
know perception attention reasoning
introspection language emotion and so on
it's very likely you'll have you'll have
consciousness as well as this is very
hard for me to see how you'd have a
system had all those things while
bypassing somehow conscious so just
naturally it's integrated quite
naturally there's a lot of overlap about
the kind of function that required to
achieve each of those things that's so
you can't disentangle them even when
you're in us but we don't know what
caused a role of consciousness in the
physical world what it does I mean just
say it turns out consciousness does
something very specific in the physical
world like collapsing wave functions as
on one common interpretation of quantum
mechanics that all we might find
someplace where it actually makes a
difference and we could say uh here is
where in collapsing wave functions it's
driving the behavior of a system and
maybe it could even turn out that for a
GI you'd need something playing that I
mean if you wanted to connect this to
free will some people think
consciousness collapsing wave functions
that would be how the conscious mind
exerts affect on the physical world and
exerts its free will and maybe it could
turn out that any AGI that didn't
utilize that mechanism would be limited
in the kinds of functionality that have
had I don't myself find that plausible I
think probably that functionality could
be simulated you could imagine once we
had a very specific idea about the role
of consciousness in the physical world
this would have some impact on the
capacity of a GIS and if it was a role
that could not be duplicated elsewhere
then we have to find we did we have to
find some way to either get
consciousness in the system to play that
role or to simulate it if we can isolate
a particular role to consciousness of
course that's incredibly seems like an
incredibly difficult thing whatever
worries about X
sensual threats of conscious intelligent
beings that are not us though so
certainly I'm sure you're worried about
us yeah from an existential threat
perspective but outside of us AI systems
there's a couple of different kinds of
existential threats here one is an
existential threat to consciousness
generally I mean yes I care about humans
and the survival of humans and so on but
just say it turns out that that
eventually we're replaced by some
artificial beings around humans but are
somehow our successes they still have
good lives they still do interesting and
wonderful things with the universe I
don't think that's that's not so bad
that's just our successors we were one
stage in evolution something different
maybe better came next if on the other
hand all of consciousness was wiped out
that would be a very serious moral
disaster one way that could happen is by
all intelligent life being wiped out and
many people think that yeah once you get
to humans and AI is an amazing
sophistication where everyone has got
the the ability to create weapons that
can destroy the whole universe just by
just by pressing a button then maybe
it's inevitable all intelligent life
will will die out that would be a that
would certainly be a disaster and we've
got to think very hard about how to
avoid that but yeah another interesting
kind of disaster is that may be
intelligent life is not wiped out but
all consciousness is wiped out so just
say you thought unlike what I was saying
a moment ago that there are two
different kinds of intelligent systems
some which are conscious and some which
are some which are not and just say it
turns out that we create AGI with with
higher degree of intelligence meaning
higher degree of sophistication and
that's behavior but with no
consciousness at all that AGI could take
over the world maybe but then there be
but let there be no consciousness in
this world this would be a world of
zombies some people have called this the
zombie apocalypse because it's
consciousness consciousness is gone
you've merely got this
/ intelligent non-conscious robots and I
would say that's a moral disaster in the
same way in almost the same way that the
world with no intelligent life is a
moral disaster all value and meaning may
be gone from from that world so these
are both threats to watch out for now my
own view is if you get super
intelligence you're almost certainly
going to bring consciousness with it so
I hope that's not gonna happen but of
course I don't understand consciousness
no one understands consciousness this is
one reason for this is one reason at
least among many for thinking very
seriously about consciousness and
thinking about the kind of future we
want to create with a you know city in a
world with humans and or AI how do you
feel about the possibility of
consciousness so naturally does come
with a GI systems that we are just a
step in the evolution that will be just
something a blimp on the record that be
studied in books by the a GI systems
centuries from now I mean I think I'd
probably be ok with that
especially if somehow humans are
continuous with AG eyes I mean I think
something like this is inevitable the
very least humans are gonna be
transformed we're gonna be augmented by
technology that's already happening in
all kinds of ways we're gonna be
transformed by technology where our
brains are gonna be uploaded and
computationally enhanced and eventually
that line between what's a human and
what's a what's an AI maybe kind of hard
to hard to draw how much does it matter
for example that some future being a
thousand years from now that somehow
descended from us actually still has
biology I think it would be nice if you
kind of point to its cognitive system to
point to some past that had some roots
in us and chaser trace a continuous line
there that would be selfishly nice for
me to think that ok I'm connected to
this thread line through the future of
the world but if it turns out ok there's
a jump there they'd if they found a
better way to design cognitive systems
they designed a wholly new kind of thing
and the only line is some causal chain
of designing and systems that design
better systems is that so much worse I
don't know
still at least part of a causal chain of
design and yes they're not humans but
still they're our successes ultimately I
think it's probably inevitable that
something like that will happen at least
we were at least we were part of the
process it'll be nice if they still
cared enough about us to you know maybe
to engage with our arguments I'm really
hoping that the Agis are gonna solve all
the problems of philosophy they'll come
back and read all this all this crap for
the 20th and 21st century hard problem
of consciousness and here is why they
got it wrong and so and if that happened
then I'd really feel like I was part of
at least a intellectual process over
centuries and that would be kind of cool
I'm pretty sure they would clone or they
would recreate David Chalmers and for
the fun of it sort of bring back other
philosophy a car the garden and just put
them in a room he's just watch it'll be
a Netflix of the future show will you
bring philosophers from different human
100% human philosophers from previous
generations put them in a room and see
them
I am totally I'm totally up for that
simulators AG eyes of the future if
you're watching who that would like to
be recreated and who wouldn't be cut
with the car it would be the first
hangout as part of such a TV show with a
philosopher that's no longer with us
from long ago who would it who would you
choose dick count would have to be right
up there oh actually a couple of months
ago I got to have a conversation with
dick Hart an actor who's actually a
philosopher came out on stage playing
Descartes I didn't know this was gonna
happen and I just after I gave a talk
and a bit of a surreal my ideas were
crap and all drive from him and so I
made along with a long argument this was
great no I would love to see what
Descartes would think about AI for
example and modern neuroscience and so
on I suspect not too much would surprise
him but that ya William James you know
for psychologists of consciousness I
think James was probably the was
probably the the richest but oh there
are manual cars you know I never really
understood when
is up to if I got to actually talk to
him about some of this hey it was
Princess Elizabeth who talked with
Descartes and who really you know got
other problems of how they carts ideas
of a non-physical mind interacting with
the with the the physical body couldn't
really work she's been kind of most
philosophers think she's been proved
right so maybe put me in a room with
Descartes and Princess Elizabeth and we
can all argue it out what kind of
feature so we talked about was zombies a
concerning future but what kind of
future excites you what do you think if
we look forward sort of we're at the
very early stages of understanding
consciousness and we're now at the early
stages of being able to engineer complex
interesting systems that have degrees of
intelligence maybe one day we'll have
degrees of consciousness maybe be able
to upload brains all those possibilities
virtual reality what is there a
particular aspect of this future world
that just excites you I think there are
lots of different aspects I mean frankly
I want it to hurry up and half us like
yeah we've had some progress lately an
AI and VR but in the grand scheme of
things it's still kind of slow the
changes are not yet transformative and
you know I'm in my 50s I've only got so
long left I'd like I'd like to see
really serious AI in my lifetime and
really serious virtual worlds because
yeah once people are I would like to be
able to hang out in a virtual reality
which is richer then then then this
reality to really get to inhabit
fundamentally different kinds of spaces
well I would very much like to be able
to upload my mind onto a onto a computer
so maybe I don't have to die if this is
maybe gradually replace my neurons with
silicon chips and I'd have it like a few
selfishly that would be that would be
wonderful I suspect I'm not going to
quite get there in a in my lifetime but
once that's possible then you've got the
possibility of transforming your
consciousness in remarkable ways or
renting it enhancing it
so let me ask them if such a system is a
possibility within your lifetime and you
were given the opportunity to become
immortal in this kind of way would you
choose to be immortal yes I totally
would I know some people say they
couldn't it would be awful to be a to be
immortal be so boring or something I
don't see I really don't see a don't see
why this might be I mean even if it's
just ordinary life that continues
ordinary life is not so bad but
furthermore I kind of suspect that you
know if the universe is gonna go on
forever or indefinitely it's going to
continue to be interesting it I don't
think yeah your view was that we just
hit this one romantic point of interest
now and afterwards it's all gonna be
boring super-intelligent stasis I guess
my vision is more like no it's gonna
continue to be infinitely interesting
something like as you go up the set
theoretic hierarchy you know you go from
the the finite car
finite Cardinals to Aleph zero and then
through there to all the Aleph one and I
love two and maybe the continuum and you
keep taking power sets and you know in
set theory they've got these results
that actually all this is fundamentally
unpredictable it doesn't follow any
simple computational patterns there's
new levels of creativity as the set
theoretic universe expands and expands I
guess that's my future that's my vision
of the future
that's my optimistic vision of the
future of superintelligence it will keep
expanding and keep growing but still
being fundamentally unpredictable at
many points I mean yes this gets creates
all kinds of worries like couldn't it
all be fragile and be destroyed at any
point so we're gonna need a solution to
that problem if we get to stipulate that
I'm immortal well I hope that I'm not
just immortal and stuck in the single
world forever but I'm immortal and get
to take part in this process of going
through infinitely rich created futures
rich unpredictable exciting well I think
I speak for a lot of people in saying I
hope you do become immortal and there'll
be that Netflix show the future where
you get to argue with
Descartes perhaps for all eternity so
David was an honor thank you so much for
talking today thanks it was a pleasure
thanks for listening to this
conversation and thank you to our
presenting sponsored cash app download
it use coal XPath cast you'll get ten
dollars and ten dollars will go to first
an organization that inspires and
educates young minds to become science
and technology innovators of tomorrow if
you enjoyed this podcast subscribe on
youtube give it five stars an apple
podcast follow on Spotify supported on
patreon or simply connect with me on
Twitter and lex friedman and now let me
leave you with some words from david
chalmers
materialism is a beautiful and
compelling view of the world but to
account for consciousness we have to go
beyond the resources it provides
thank you for listening I hope to see
you next time
you